Great.
Hello and welcome everyone to Active Lab.
Today is April 28th, 2021.
It's ActInf Lab
Guesttream number 5.1 with Martin
Biehl.
Martin, thanks so much for joining us
on today's stream.
And we're really looking forward
to hearing about your perspective
and what you have to share here.
So if anyone in the live
chat would like to ask
questions, we'll be relaying those to you
during and at the end of the stream.
Other than that, please take it away.
And thanks again for coming on.
Thank you.
Oh, Daniel.
Welcome to my talk, everybody.
I would talk about
I will talk about,
at least in the background
about the paper.
I wrote it all up and real text night,
which is called Technical Critique
of some part of the free
energy principle. But
I will
not go directly through this paper.
I will kind of try to give a more updated
perspective.
Yeah, what I have to say, I work at Araya
in Tokyo
and this work is also funded
by a charity foundation
and Felix was supported
by the Monash University.
Okay, so
he is the
content of this talk.
Let's make some preliminary remarks
and then
talk about my perspective
basically on the free energy principle
and how it can
maybe maybe split into two parts,
the construction of agents
and the identification of agents.
And then
I'll talk about what
the FP agent constructs is
and what the FP agent ID
method kind of is.
And then I'll talk about the relation
between those
or at least a claims relation
between those.
And then I'll go through some issues
with this agent
ID method and also with this relation.
Okay.
So yeah, like I said,
the main publication
is the same name
as the has
the same title as it's talk and
email this year.
And it resulted from an effort
with Phenix
where we, we actually set out to do
a, like a descriptive version of the life
as we know it.
People.
But we failed.
And then in the end
we wrote this critique.
So yeah, I will,
I will give this a in this talk.
I will give
my personal view
a little bit of the free energy principle
and why I find it interesting.
And like I said,
I want to go through the paper in detail
and instead summarize
how I currently see the issues.
Also, the issues that we mentioned
in the paper, but the FFP,
FFP meets the energy principles.
That's why we were writing this paper.
It has changed and so
my perspective has also changed.
And but if you have questions,
particular questions
about the paper, then you can of course
ask me afterwards.
Okay, so here's the
maybe
a little bit more detailed overview.
So in my opinion,
the free energy principle can be viewed
as two parts of.
And the first part is basically what
maybe you've heard in this statement
that Markus Blanket implies
Markov is imply based on inference.
And I so from my perspective,
this is kind of a way to identify agents
in stochastic processes.
So this is one part
that is contained in the FP literature
and another part
is about how to construct
artificial agents for
example, for reinforcement
learning or partially observable
Markov decision problems.
And I call this to construct
different agents, but
and the claim
the claim is that
like if you read papers about this
constructing agent part,
the claim is that they
that this construction
is based on this identifying agents part.
So the construction is based on this
model and gets implication inference
part of the literature.
And I would kind of argue that this is
has not been established.
And I also kind of think it's
questionable a
at least in the current state.
Then I also present
some other issues for the FP among those
those that I mentioned in the paper
and these issues.
So yeah, one thing I want
to say is that these issues,
they kind of effect.
What effect?
I mean, if they if I'm
if I'm correct about those issues
and they affect the usefulness
of the free energy principle
for agent ID so so then we couldn't
identify agency for you and this also
as a theory of life is sort of like
general or life as we know it.
If you want.
And then
it would also affect this claim that
these create these construct
it's the energy
it's the agents are somehow
based on trust principles
more than, let's say,
some other enforcement
learning. It.
What what all of this
what all of these points, in my opinion,
what effect is
that free that these free energy
that's for agents,
free energy minimizing agents
that are constructed
in the literature that they work or
that they work at
or basically or that they can be useful
for some research.
I mean, I think I think those
I think that these agents work
is kind of independent of this whole
Markov blanket implementation in.
But maybe I'm wrong.
That's okay.
So what's this what are these two things?
Well, in the construction of agents
and the identification of agents.
So like I said, I think the literature
can be split into these two parts
and it's hard to construct
an agent or a controller
on. And the other one is how to identify
an agent
in a stochastic and American system.
And yeah, so
and like I said also before, the, the
is first method
how to construct an agents
or controller
is to inherit from second message.
And these are the claims that are
current.
So it's a paper that came out
just actually a week ago.
So I think it's called sophisticated
inference.
Okay.
So what do I mean by
construction of agents or what is this?
What is the problem
of construction of agents?
Because that's a yeah.
A different problem than the ID. Okay.
That's kind of the first point
I want to make that these two
problems are different
in general.
So yeah, in, in, in artificial
intelligence research, what,
what people are occupied with
is the construction
of intelligence agents
for some given environment or test
or like you
and yeah.
So basically what what these people do
in artificial intelligence
research or engineering
is programing robots of actual agents.
And of course, the robot
is then kind of it's
a fixed environment.
Or if you have a virtual world
and this is also fixed environment
and then if you have some reinforcement
learning problem,
then you have kind of a test.
Okay, so
like I said,
we in these cases, what we have is
some environment
that is given and I,
I write this here
is that there's a network
and then we construct a controller.
And then what it does is
we have some environment states
that call each other
and sets of values
that depend on each other.
And we have dynamics of each other.
So, so basically towards the right time
increases.
And so this is
so we have
we have some dynamics
of this environment
which tells us how ether changes
under the influence of actions
and depending on the state
and the
environment of your sense of values.
And what an agent does
is actually centenarians
and updates its internal state,
which is called new
and produces actions accordingly.
So as you see here, mute
depends on both the sentences
and the actions,
how exactly these features are.
Look, there's some variability in it,
but is roughly one one idea
like now, most of them are rough.
It's much
so, like I said,
a little bit more formally, maybe
each of t is an environment state
or an environment
or a task is defined as by
an environment state, sense of values,
some kind of action interface.
So some dependency
on the external variable.
So this dependance
the update of each on the action
and the dynamics, which means
if we have a
if we are in discrete time,
then the dynamics can be specified as
Markov kernel or conditional probability
of the next or the next
internal state and extends
the sense of are value
conditioned on the process in terms
that sense, the value and the action,
which is the inference from.
So it's
and in continuous time
we could also formulate this.
And one way to formulate
this looks like this week is the
time derivative of the part
that has some function in its own state
and the action plus some noise.
And similarly for the
sense of dynamics
and maybe
it's not so important,
but in general you can have
and an environment
can have some kind of reward
that it gives to the agent
as part of the sense of value or
it may not.
Okay. And then what's an agent?
So an agent
has this internal memory state.
And if these actions
and it also has an interface
for accepting or senses
and I produce that environment
and it's an image
this can also be written
as instead of conditional probability
or similarly
this time the written
in the time continuous state
and maybe the the main part
that's going to be relevant
or some something later in this talk
is that we can combine and we can combine
such environments and agents
and then they form a markov process.
So then we have some joint variable X
and the product of these two
conditional probabilities
for one for the environment
and the one for
the agent, they induce this
Markov kernel of the joint process.
And similarly, in the continuous case
we can see the whole thing
as one, the combination
of the environment and the agent
as a whole, as a single, very,
as a single Markov process with
State X.
Okay.
So that's kind of what
we should keep in mind
some remarks on this.
Usually we have we construct these agents
to solve some problems
so we have some kind of the what.
So this is the case in reinforcement
learning for a few entities,
but we can also have agents
that have just intrinsic goals
and they don't need any reward
from the environment.
These things are usually called
intrinsic motivations
and the these
the FP agents from the literature,
they actually kind of have both
in within them.
So they have a
they contain some part that's like
an intrinsic motivation and they also can
they have some part
that is similar to a reward.
And so basically the intrinsic motivation
for is
it's like a maximization
of information gain and the
instead of reward
maximization,
we minimize some divergence from
a desired distribution interest.
But at least on a high level,
this is seen as of
so these two things are kind of combined
in the B
and in the expected the energy.
Yeah,
I mean there are some tricks to this,
but roughly this.
Oh, sure.
Okay.
So, so that that's that's what
I hope it came across.
What I mean by construction of agents
and don't know
if there were any questions
already and it's.
Not yet continue.
Thank you. And yet. Okay.
And so then
what do
I mean by identification of agents,
which is maybe a bit less
common practice?
So first, maybe let's ask the question
what what is an agent
in general
and so very roughly,
there's a definition by
the end of an era,
and they say
to be an agent, you have to be something
that's individuated, that can act,
that makes things happen, and
an act which just means
to make things happen basically.
And it can act to achieve
these actions are performed
in order to achieve some goal.
So an agent does go
maybe something that has a goal, an X
to achieve,
actively pursue some school.
And these
these agents that I just talked
about these construct the agents that we
construct in artificial intelligence
but also in the literature.
They are agents because they are.
And if by construction
they are individuated
because we kind of know
where their boundary is.
Like if you ask some engineer
what they have to do to construct
the agent, they know exactly what to do.
So they they seem to know
where the agent's is or what
the agent is.
And of course,
since we programed into them
the intrinsic motivation
or some kind of reward
maximization mechanism,
they are also directed
by construction.
Okay, so but then this is not
just for what agents are.
So what's what's what about?
I don't dislocation of agents
so the the and this for me
the origin of this question
is the kind of
the problem of agents in physics.
So the physicists they tell us
that everything is determined
by the laws of physics.
So that means everything that happens
is made happen by the laws of physics
and not by any thing within this
within the universe.
So in this,
if they are correct, then nothing within
the universe can make anything. It.
But that also means
that nothing can act to achieve a goal
because nothing can make anything happen.
So you can't act to achieve some goal
because you can't act in the substance.
So this seems to suggest
that basically there are no agents
and they don't think that
it must be some kind of illusion.
But at the same time,
I mean, we are here,
we are agents and we kind of want to
we kind of have goals,
or at least it seems extremely likely.
And it also seems like
there are things that don't.
And we
built these robots
and they seem to be quite real things.
And I'm of course also
so it's kind of
so maybe there is some way
there should be some way
to make these things
compatible with.
So what we want is that if you are,
if you like the
physicist perspective
and also you like
you like to think about agents, then
you maybe you want what you want to form
a theory of agents that is compatible
physics.
And then
so one one problem
that such any such theory
should be able to solve is that if
you have some kind of universe
and in physics
that's basically just done in a system,
then what and where are the agents?
So if you have that, if you have a formal
definition of agents
or formal theory of agents, then
this is a question that it should
probably be able to answer.
So here's the universe.
And what we want to do
is we want to check where inside this
long history of the universe,
there are these things
that are maybe chemical agents like this.
Anybody
a bit more formally.
So we have some kind of
in physics,
we have some kind of dynamical system.
We have a state space
and states
and we have a dynamical law that is
look maybe looks like this.
The time derivative of y
is some function of the.
So the time derivative
of the state of the universe
is a function
of the current state of the universe.
And then we have
so these things have trajectories.
And if we select
one of those trajectories
by some initial condition, y zero,
then what we would expect from
a theory about
a theory of agents
and one that can also identify agents,
then what we would want
is that this theory gives us,
like once we give it such a trajectory
of the dynamical system, or
maybe the trajectory and the dynamics of
that, this theory tells us
what is the set of agents
contained in this trajectory.
And it should tell us this, including
what is basically its body
or its individual, what is the individual
to the actions and all the other goals?
Okay.
So this is what I think is kind of the
agent identification problem
and the FP
does something like this.
They start not directly, maybe
with a deterministic dynamical system
and stuff is maybe
like,
but they instead start with something
that's usually considered
a subsystem
of such a deterministic universe.
And this subsystem should obey
this kind of large
of an equation.
And then the FP kind of tells us what
how to like conditions under
which there's an agent inside
such a thing.
So I'm not sure how this relates to this,
the exact formulation I gave here where
you just get a trajectory and the system
and it tells you where the agents are
and some subtleties to this.
But but roughly
I think the energy principle
is definitely a step towards
such a theory.
And this part
of the free energy principle
is what I call the free energy principle
ID, the FP agent ID method.
And it is
if you are familiar with the literature,
this is where
the Markov blanket plays
a fundamental role.
The so-called mark of speculations.
Okay.
Barton, they ask, What do we gain or lose
by by going to the lines
of an equation, what is what is gained
or lost in that maneuver
relative to the more general phrasing
you had on the previous slide?
Yeah, good question.
So I well, I don't really know.
I all I can say is that
yeah,
I mean, one thing you definitely gain
is that if you I mean, this thing,
it's kind of hopeless.
Like if you would really
if you
if we would need the particle physics
equation, then
we would probably never be able
to identify it.
Agents Because the particle, I mean, it's
just too complicated and complex
to say much about it.
But so here this gives us kind of
we can kind of say, okay,
I can ignore a lot of stuff
and all I have to find
is some kind of part of the system that
obeys
some kind of approximate equation,
basically.
And this can be enough.
So this is, I guess, this one
one advantage.
Yeah.
I mean, like, there's one other thing
I'm not sure.
I mean, there's one other thing
I sometimes think
where this might be useful for and that's
so what we what we kind of want
is that
this agent theory,
I mean, if you think about it, basically
a billion
yet like a few at some point,
there probably weren't
any agents inside the universe.
So, so at that point.
So so agents kind of
like a full blown theory of agents.
They should
it should allow trajectories
with within which agents appear
and basically disappear,
or at least
they have to be able to appear,
because that's kind of what we think
the universe happened in the universe.
And but this is not
this kind of appearance and disappearance
is actually not so easy to to do,
especially if you would just kind of
naively split up this system,
the whole system into two parts
and say it is one part the agent and one
the environment, because then you split
it basically all the time
and this kind of weird
because how because you
you would want that
the split only works for a short time
or once they actually
is an agent.
So sometimes I think okay maybe
maybe this is the approximate equation
only works for a short time
and that's an advantage of this also that
there might be short time frames
where this equation works and with it
and others where it doesn't work
and then we could get
we could think about whether this means
the agent appears or not.
But actually, I'm not so sure
what you see and what the details.
So yeah,
that's all I can really say it is.
I mean, I think yeah, it's,
but it's a very good question.
I think.
Thanks.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Because it would be a reasonable point.
But not
yet, but anyone is welcome to do so.
Thank you though.
Okay.
So how does the FP construct agents?
I'm not going to talk about this a lot,
but just maybe I'm only going to
maybe mention the things
that are relevant later.
And this is basically just the district
I am free energy minimizing agents.
So in the free energy
front, in the literature, especially
the early ones, you also have
a continuous time
free energy minimizing agents. But
yeah, I'm going to mostly for them.
Yeah, they're not very
there's nothing in particular
I want to say about them.
But then
so in this discrete time
energy, in this good time FP agents,
the agents state you
consists of
hyper perimeters.
Basically
I put parameters for the conjugate price
of the model that this agent is
constructed to
use basically.
And these hypothermia just they insult
the beliefs of
both the environment state
that basically
a model of the environment and
a model of the dynamics.
Sometimes there's no model
of the environment dynamics, but it's
so this kind of important.
I mean, they basically yeah.
So the actual state consists
of these hyper parameters.
Um, and then what happens,
what happens with this
is that in response
to some observation and action,
the agent updates
the beliefs.
And actually that just means
that it updates these type of parameters.
And this is under variation of base.
And then the agent basically
it also has a
belief over actions
and this also gets update
and this is done in such a way that it
minimizes the expected free energy,
which I think I've mentioned this
before, maximizes information
gain and kind of minimizes
the divergence from these
maybe somewhat relevant.
Instead, if the model class
that the agent maintains
contains the true
content, basically the true
the truth, the true model, then
what exact model of the involved island
and so on.
Then the belief update
this variation of belief update actually
is the same as the exact page number.
Okay, so that's already all I say about
the FP Agent Construction.
And now I talk a bit about how the FP
agent ID works.
So the the main
relevant literature
on this
agent ID
wallpapers, papers as far as I can see.
And the first one is life as we know it,
interest on 13.
And then there's a
monograph
quite a long
paper
thing on an 80 page
something or 80 page, lots of pages.
And that's called a free energy
principle for particular physics.
And there's
kind of an extract
from that, but it's small differences
and it's called
Markov think it's information,
geometry and dynamics.
I'm as far
and you know
and also first and
hello
and then there's also a paper
which is written in response
to our criticism.
That's
some interesting
observations on the free energy
principle.
It's a question.
No, sorry.
Yes. So
okay, so this
this last paper was in response or.
Correct.
So these I think these contain basically
what the
these contain
all the things relevant to this
agent ID them.
And basically, they're the main paper.
It's not it's not I could think
there are also some other ones,
but I think actually these ones are the
essentials.
Okay.
Yeah, our the paper we wrote, it's
mainly concerned with life as we know it
because the second
none of the other papers existed
when we started writing it, the,
this one and every principle
before particular physics came up
and we were and we
and when we were writing it.
But yeah, as I said, I would try,
I would try to
give a fact if that also includes
the newer
constructional approach of for papers.
Okay.
Yeah.
So what is the rough idea of this?
I can't go through this in detail mainly
or among other reasons for this
is that I don't really know.
I don't really understand how it works.
And it's like I I'm still not
I haven't gone through
the whole construction
because I get
usually I, it's just stuck before
I'm through.
Okay.
So the rough idea is so
we have our universe
and like I said, we find this
subsystem
that okay, it's
the length of an equation.
Omega
is some kind of markov and white noise.
Then we also require that this
subsystem or Yeah.
Is such that not only does it
obey this equation,
but also that this equation
has a steady state distribution.
P star
okay.
I think there's just going to be
the same thing in response.
Oh, okay.
So now what we're going to do
is we find this subsystem
basically, let's say
we have this system and it appears this
equation, things are basically
imagined environment with this animal
and now with further split up this
system.
So well, I thought
there was going to be some answer.
So we further split up the system.
Basically, we are
we split it up into here.
You you basically
I hope you can kind of see that this
central nervous system of this animal
and we kind of
split that up, this whole system
into relevant into parts
that are aligned with agents in some way.
That's sort
of like
now, okay,
that's what we're going to do afterwards
in one step.
But first,
I understand it's confusing, but
there is
one nice fact
about
so this should have been before this.
And I just
there's one nice fact
about these kind of equations.
So I just go back
to about these kind of equations
if they have a steady state distribution
and only if they have a steady
set distribution.
If they don't,
then you can't do the following.
So, so in that case,
if they have a steady distribution,
then you can write F of X
as this
kind of gradient descent
or SNF,
which I
formulated
of the log probability of the log
of the stationary distribution.
And yeah, so then you also
get these two matrices here in front
and are symmetric and symmetric.
And also yeah, you can write this
here, the log for the log
they said probability
you can write it or turn it into this
negative log probability
and that's the definition of this.
I you've maybe seen in the
the surprise.
Okay yeah.
That this is not really trivial of this
when exactly you can
write it's not really trivial
especially
when this come up
matrix and our matrix don't
depend on the position
x, which is something that
is usually assumed in the FIP
literature.
Yeah. I mean if if the force is linear
or if
the vector fields or something
sort of got lowest anyhow, then
it works.
And this also means
that there are six points
of a nonlinear active field.
It books.
Okay.
I asked a question on that last slide,
Martin.
If I'm maybe giving an example
of a kind of system
that people apply it to, what is X here?
And then what does it mean
that R is anti symmetric and that gamma
is symmetric?
Okay.
So I actually don't know.
I don't think anybody applies this
to anything
that you think
at least.
Yeah, I mean, like that's
actually one of the criticisms I have,
but we can definitely apply it to some
systems and maybe I'm going to
look somewhere deep on there up there was
on these pictures that snow
is get trapped in those
I thought okay yeah yeah.
Okay so
here's a 2D example of such an equation
and with the comma and the R,
so we say this
falls, let's say this forces
or this vector, this linear.
So it's just the matrix times the vector.
So then exactly.
Then we have this matrix
types of state and
we get this equation and we can
find Gamma and R.
You can compute them
this way in the literature.
Sure.
You can also see it
and it's also mentioned in our paper
out computers.
And you can and we can compute
the stationary distribution.
It's some kind of Gaussian in this case.
And it looks like this.
And you see, here's the on the left,
you see this vector field
and on the right you see the steady state
distribution.
He had got ecologic density,
but that's the same thing.
And how do they split up slope?
So if you look at the component, gamma
times, the gradient,
you get this vector field.
And if you look at the control and
this should be
there are sometimes it's called.
Q But that's the same thing.
Just in case you're wondering,
if you look at the
component R, then it has this
it's basically this circular
component of
this vector.
It's hard to see that
this vector has this circular component,
but if you see it roughly here,
you see that they actually aren't.
So this one is actually straight always
or so.
The left one is the hill climbing aspect
and the right side is the
is it sometimes called solenoid L
or the ISO contour?
Yes. So exactly.
And so there is one
interesting thing about this,
and that's that
this is the
so whether this matrix R is
everywhere, zero or not, two sides,
whether
the steady state
is the Non-Equilibrium state
or an equilibrium steady state.
And this is due to
the I mean, so the standard definition of
non-equilibrium
steady state and equilibrium
or distinction between non-equilibrium
steady state and
equilibrium state.
Is it is that
in the equilibrium steady state,
you have to balance that
in the non-equilibrium that it's not.
And if you have this cylindrical flow,
then you don't have to you.
That's exactly when you don't have
it basically destroys
that it's a advance.
Thanks.
Yeah yeah.
So it's a balance means that
basically if you
if you make a square, small square here
and the flow
or two let's take two neighboring
squares
and then if it had teacher balance,
then the flow from one square to
the other would always be
the same as the square
from the other to the first,
from the second to the first.
But since here,
this flow always goes in, in this
horizontal direction. I'm
not horizontal in this side direction.
What goes in from
the one side is never compensated
in the other direction.
So then you can say here,
but on the left side
it also doesn't
look like it's compensated.
And that's that's that's true.
But it is actually compensated by the
noise because this is only a
this is
only the the vector field
and without the noise factor.
So this only F of X
without the most factor
and the noise factor in this because it's
the noise factor is also it has no curve.
So this is why you
so the noise can compensate.
There's this
component, but it cannot.
All right,
maybe that was a bit
maybe I shouldn't
have taken that much expense, but
it's kind of nice
and we're very.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah. So
this is what we get,
this nice composition
and it's kind of needed oil.
We only get it if we have this
the steady state. It's
and it plays a reasonably important role
in the
literature.
Okay.
So this other thing
that we do
with our subsystem
is we split it up in some way.
And this is kind of what the Markov,
the so called Markov
think it does.
So the but I'm just going to
I'm not going to talk about what to
make of this yet.
I'm just going to
say what it's
so about the work
that it's supposed to do.
So it will give us
this split of the state
into all of the state coordinates
into four parts,
basically a partition of the coordinates
and and
we will then call
each to the external states
as to the sensory state and the active
and actually states
at the internal state. State
and then also so
sorry, someone else just joined.
We'll set a question.
Oh, no, no, no.
Someone else just joined in.
Not actually sure, but still, Avi
and I'll add a little
password
just so that no one else joins in.
You have to go for it.
Okay.
So so then
what the microphone also does
basically it does all kinds of
it does a lot of work.
Let's put it this way,
because all you need is that you
have this subsystem and you have
the study set at the mark of blanket.
And then what you get
is that the internal, active
and sensory states
in this system appear to
and this is important actively
resist
the dispersion of its mark of packets.
Okay, well,
there's split microphone and again,
so here you should read boundary
or you can also read individuality.
That's what this means in this case,
by engaging in approximate
Bayesian inference. So
so these this statement
basically has all these features
that we kind of
want from an agent, identify, location
theory
because it tells us that if we have this
under these conditions
and by naming these
variables in this way,
then we see that these
mean basically it's it makes sense
to name these variables in this way
because they
we have some kind of goal.
The goal is
to resist dispersion of the microphone,
I guess.
So basically it's the goal,
this kind of persistence
and the agent acts
to pursue this thought
because it actively resists
this distortion.
Yeah.
And it is individuated because we have to
we know which states belong to it
and which basically top it off it.
It's this distinction
between external and internal.
Yeah.
And then additionally, which is also
kind of nice that this all this agent
is also doing some kind of approximate
Bayesian inference, which is a
bonus, I guess.
So this is why I,
I say that
the FCP basically is contains
the theory of agent ID and
yeah.
That this is yeah.
And this is also
this is basically the part
that interests me the most about the
standard treatments.
It's okay.
It's kind of a
maybe a unique selling point
compared to all other kinds of
sort, to most other approaches, to
obstructing
logical agents.
And it's also I mean, there are not many
there are not many
agent ID theories
that I know of,
and I actually hope that I know of them.
But yeah, actually that yeah.
It's quite a these aren't common.
Okay.
Yeah.
I said what this is, it's okay.
Yeah. So in summary,
we just make three assumptions.
We say, well,
some subsystem has dynamics,
it has a sense that this region
and it has Marcos think that Eduardo
we have identified
an edge.
Yeah, nice.
Sounds good.
Okay, so let me.
Is there any question up to now?
There's a few more general ones,
but feel free to continue
and we'll get them, I think, at the end,
because this next section
will probably very helpful.
Okay.
So so now
let's talk about
what the relation between this FP
agent construction and FP agent ID
parts of the F in the literature
are according to the literature.
So the
these I kind of said this already, but
the thing that makes FP
more active inference,
those are actually the same thing
as far as I know
agent special it is that
lots of things are at least two things.
I mean, there might be more,
but I think these are the main ones
or the most important
ones to this.
These are
FP agents, the construct
they've constructed, FP agents
that I talked about before.
They can be seen as kind of a class
or used.
They are used kind of
as a plausible model in neuroscience.
And this relates
to predictive coding and based frame.
But I actually I'm not qualified
to talk about this because I don't know
enough about neuroscience.
But the other thing that makes them
special is
one of the main points
I mean, of this talk is
that they are claimed
to be based on first principles.
And when the statement
that they're based on first principles
actually means refers exactly to this
the this FP
ancient identification method.
So the first principles
are basically what I just
talked about that the
last equation and the steady state
and the mark of
it gives you this agent.
So let's
in order to make sure
we're not putting words
into the mouth of the literature
that's read this quote once
that's from the also sophisticated
paper that just came out.
The key distinction is that base
adaptive enforcement learning considers
arbitrary what functions
by a sophisticated active inference
optimizes an expected free energy
that can be motivated from
okay, actually here
it doesn't say best
but actually in another like you can
get this paper in
in another place it says based on first
and also this is not only
this is not only
mentioned
for the sophisticated inference agents
you will see some statements
in the literature,
in other tests.
So this is I mean, this kind of
in some
way, it's super cool if it's true.
I think.
But I'm not so sure it's true.
Okay.
So some notes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, so this is about
whether actually this
how important is that is
how important is it for
the constructed agents
to be based on this first instance?
So in this
kind of sophisticated inference paper,
the authors say that
the agents expected free energy
at expected free energy,
which is the thing that many of us
can be motivated from first.
But they also
seem to say
that the expected free energy can also be
I mean, yeah, actually,
I mean, they say in one
they say that it can also be motivated
by the information we don't.
And they are all
I mean, there's
there's one part that this refers to.
So as far as I understand it, they are
there's a there are two ways to motivate
this expected free energy minimization.
And one is via
these first principles and one is via
some other derivation
that involves information.
Now, I would say
I understand these derivations
the statement completely, but
I do know that there's a paper by Cohen
and Tarter
and they show that if you that there's a
that that basically some combination
of information gain and reward
maximization
is you can prove
that it's optimal in some sense.
So since this expected free energy
is kind of a combination
of those two things,
I kind of think,
let's put it this way,
I'm not surprised that it has
it shows good performance
or something like this because maybe it's
actually so closely
related to the method by Cohen that.
It just works.
So all I'm saying,
I guess what I want to say is that
in case
the motivation of first principles
fails, the FP construction of
agents may still be of interest
and might still work.
And this also means that all these
all publications, I think they are some.
But yeah, I think that maybe quite a few
of these publications that
that are basically based on this
expected free energy
of minimum minimizing agents
are they
they need not be without merit
just because the
first principles motivation fails
so or in other words
they can still they
they can still make as much sense
basically even if this free energy
principle agent ID is wrong.
If I could ask a question here, Martin,
What what kind of first principles
are you most interested in?
And then what kind of a theory of agents
or agency would be satisfying,
given your interest in first principles?
Yeah, I mean, I, I, I think so.
So if you
like the,
I'm interested in the first principles
that work.
I don't know what
the first principles are,
but like maybe one, one sentence
is that you can start from physics.
Like that's like you can you
you start with some well
I don't know where I'll have to go
up. Yeah.
Some of that is, is
you start with the dynamical system
and you then
derive using only
notions
that are well-defined for dynamic systems
or within such dynamical systems
to show that
this thing,
this system contains agents or not.
Or so I guess the first principles for
the first principles here are that,
okay, all we have to believe is
that there are such subsystems
that obey the laws of equations.
And I guess since the laws
of equation has been quite
popular in physics, it has
this, has this, this,
this has some strong support.
And maybe that's sufficient
to be your first principle.
Also, having steady state is fine.
It's rare to find there's no I mean,
that's a mathematically fine thing.
We can in principle
check this
so yeah.
Then the other thing that's used in
the literature
is the Markov linkage.
And I think that's also yeah, it's a
it could be a well-defined thing.
I think it's a bit of a like
what it means in the FP literature
is kind of not, it's
not really clear and it changes
and maybe it has to change again,
but at least the original.
So it depends.
Yeah, I guess I have to
I would have to solve it more, but
Markov thank you.
But yeah, I would say
I yeah, for first principle for me means
probably just that you have to be able
to define it for
dynamic.
It has to be like all the notions of use.
You can only use notions
that are defined for dynamic. It
totally makes sense.
It's like if you're going to play
the game of dynamical systems analysis,
you can only use those rules.
Exactly.
You can only things like you have to
you have to construct everything
from there.
You don't get anything else.
That's it.
You get the dynamic sense of
Yeah.
Okay,
that's.
Yep. That's
yep, that's is it.
Not even.
Yep. Okay. So now.
Oh, okay.
So that's
a big part of the talk.
That's
kind of that was kind of my personal,
my current personal view on what's
yeah.
And how I
yeah, how I look at the FP literature and
what it is I guess, and
yeah, so now I would go and talk about
the issues I see with this.
FP interest identification method,
but if there's any questions now
might be, what's the point?
That's it for now, definitely.
After this,
we'll see if anyone has any questions,
but feel free to type them
in the live chat if anyone has it.
Okay, so
the first is, should I have instead
this Markov blanket assumption
is known to be insufficient
and now it's not very interesting.
Maybe in the
maybe at the for the very first paper,
it was known to be
okay actually for the papers.
Maybe
now I don't know.
Yeah, I can't really say
because it wasn't me.
But it's fair to say that
the first two papers
that might not have known this.
Okay. Yeah.
So, so, so I'm going to kind of
go through the Markov
blanket evolution a little bit,
not not another energy term, but
the mark of blanket evolution
in the FP literature.
Or maybe I should say that originally I,
I think I'll have to see you.
I mentioned it on the okay.
So originally the term
I think it comes from Judea Pearl
from this 19 aged book.
Yeah.
So it's a, it's a technical term
that had a definition before
it was used by the ethical literature.
Okay.
So and in this, in this original paper,
the knife as we know it,
there is actually no definition of like
there's no no, it's no, we're clear.
It's it's not clearly said what is meant.
What kind of mark of blanket is meant.
I mean, there's some kind of graph
but Markov blankets
come from directed acyclic graphs
and the graph is cyclic, so
it's actually not know what it's meant.
I mean there is,
but it clearly states that
that's the mark of blankets that
are should imply this equation
that the vector field
when we split it up
into the four coordinates
also edge it.
So it's kind of nice also that there are
these four you can split up the fact
that the corner four sets
of all the coordinates
into four sets of corners
and the vector field
then as can be
has a certain shape form
namely at the
internal and sensory states do not
that the vector field components
of the internal and sensory states do not
directly depend on the internal state
and the vector field components
of the action and excellent active
internal states do not depend
directly on the external. This
maybe.
But yeah,
and we call this
a we we we call this vector condition or
or I mean, I call
this because it's
the condition of the vector C
and in our paper this is conditional.
Okay?
This is kind of, I think in life
as we know it, this is kind of
this is the only
real thing
is where
the macro blanket plays a role.
And by the way,
this is not a michael Frank.
I mean, not technically this
not the thing.
I mean, this is a purely
and mark of its condition.
Then in
at least in and Thomas
Price paper in 2020,
the mark of blanket is said to imply
this condition
independence of the
external states
given blanket, which are the sensory
and the actual states.
So we get this factorization
of the stationary distribution
or a steady state distribution
and that's
also considered
a condition of the mark of
this thing is also implicit in the
this condition is also implicit.
It's in the
free energy principle
for particular physics,
but it's not explicitly referred to
as the Marcos make sense of it.
But this is actually a mark of locus
in the sense of true.
Therefore this condition is a true mark
and it has
come to be called
not only by me,
the time synchronous,
synchronous mark of condition.
And in our paper this is condition.
Those two conditions,
this one and condition one.
They are independent of each other
like they are systems that obey this one
and not this one.
And system the systems that obey this one
and not this.
And those systems are not
complicated.
They are actually linear systems.
So they are this constant. One factor
first, since they can easily compute
this stationary distribution
and it's a gas.
So you can look this in the in the paper.
And I think I think one of the I mean,
this is why it's speculation, but
I think that the
the authors
are confused
because the only offer
kind of thought that this equate that
this condition implies this condition.
I it seems to me
there are various reasons, but
and I'm not going to go into it,
but this seems to be the case
and maybe you could think I mean, I can
you could think this.
I mean, not completely of
question, but yeah.
So then
we wrote we wrote this paper
after we wrote this paper in 2000, 19
and complained
about some,
some thing in the
some things in the
free energy
for fairness
principle for particular physics,
paper, namely
this thing called
the conditional independence corollary,
which is supposed to follow
from the vector of your condition.
I think
is to I mean, I think that's the claim.
But we showed that it doesn't.
And so then the mark of blanket by then
the and an additional condition
was presented
in this paper called
some interesting observations.
Oh about the energy
principle of something.
This is the responsible paper
that this condition
is that the sun needle
component matrix
are or Q as this shape.
Okay that's why
I mean I'm going to call this
first line condition if I ever need
it again in this so but okay
yeah since this came out after I mean,
this was in response to our paper,
so we don't really talk about this.
Okay? So
this is just some additional condition
and then I think so,
yeah.
So you can kind of see all of these
like these conditions are all used in
to derive this statement here that
that this statement here,
the FP agent identification method
basically that you get to identify
that we actually get
we can identify an agent that actively
acts to that, that acts to
assist
basically with the goal of just, okay,
so we have this addition as well.
And then in,
in part in the first paper
and also in the monograph,
if we look closely, there's
actually an additional assumption made
in the free
energy principle for particular physics.
It's claimed to be a consequence
of the other conditions,
but that's not true.
We can show this.
It's kind of easy.
And in the pop space, it's
actually said that it's an assumption.
So we've known that
this is an additional assumption.
And this assumption
is that there's some function sigma
and this function
sigma relates to variables.
And these two variables are
the most likely,
except that both it's a given the
like a s estimate
and the most likely internal state
given the and
according to citation or
of the states statistics
and the
and so sigma is the assumption
is that that
that there exists a function
sigma that maps one that maps
the most likely
internal state to the most
likely external state
and that that this function
doesn't need to exist.
You can see,
for example,
I mean, it's it's not in our paper,
we should have probably put it
in our paper, but we didn't.
The contact sample is you can use
basically the system we have.
We show an appendix T
and then we show one of those linear
video systems again.
And for this, the both view is just
one half a
and the both it has one half s
and since s of T it's
not a function of MFT and basically
so they are kind of
so every combination of SMP can occur.
So there is no functional relation
between the two.
And that means they also kind of
cannot be any function
sigma.
So so this means we kind of have
to additionally assume sigma
and also, you know.
Yeah, and the thing is in my opinion,
this sigma might actually be
a much stronger,
the strongest of all of these functions
that are made make stronger than any
of the other conditions.
And these other three conditions,
the vectors, the TSMC and the just
and linear condition,
I think that's probably the most work.
But since I don't really understand
the whole picture,
I really tell for sure. But
so yeah, we'll just.
Just summary that Sigma
is sort of the proposed function
that's literally
linking internal and external.
So when we're talking about agents
and the way
that their internal generative model
is being linked to generative processes
in the outside world,
that's like the key link. That's
what we're all about.
So I totally
I totally see where you're coming from.
Thank you.
That's a good
that's a good way to say it. Exactly.
I mean, yeah, think I would
I would say this later again.
But let me just say, it's already
these three conditions.
They are all trivially satisfied
by four independent stochastic processes.
So like it seems
kind of
unrealistic,
let's put it this way,
that any of these conditions
by themselves or even their combination,
would be sufficient to
give us
this kind of active,
active resistance to anything.
It's like modeling of the environment
or on
occasion inference about the environment
because
for independence, suggested processes
don't seem to.
I mean, it would be hard to argue
that any of those is doing
anything is modeling
any of your thoughts.
So yeah, exactly.
This is
but if you have such a relation
then yeah.
Then yeah,
there might be something going on.
Okay.
So in summary,
we have these four conditions,
the vector field condition,
the MVC, the sign
and the sigma function exists.
And I would say
maybe of those the FIP blanket together.
Okay.
Okay. Here, I say this though.
Apart from the sequence function,
all the conditions are satisfied
by four independent linear
stochastic processes because once
yeah.
So of probably sickness.
The most
significant assumption
and yeah,
I mean it's maybe a petty point
but I kind of think that calling
the combination of these conditions
blanket is
at least I mean,
but by now it is definitely misleading.
I mean, I think the use of this word,
Michael
think it was misleading before,
but I think
it should probably be dropped.
But anyway, I'm going to call it
FIP, Blanket
upset this
so and one more thing.
I am not
I, I cannot say that these conditions,
these four conditions together
together are sufficient for
the whole
FIP agent ID argument
just because I don't, I haven't really
gotten through the whole thing.
But we know
that they are necessary.
I mean, they are
used in these agreements.
Okay.
So that's the first
that was the first issue.
How am I doing in time
since I've already on?
You can go for as long as you want
and we can go as long as you are already.
At one hour, 20.
Well.
You can go
as long as you want today, MARTIN
And then we can always schedule
another time to speak.
But this is really, really helpful.
And I'm sure that a lot of people
are going to digest it,
have a lot to talk to you about.
Okay. Okay.
And I'm just asking and to okay,
all right.
Next one,
this point is not in our paper.
I guess
it has been in the back of our heads.
But I mean, I think it's it's
really also it's become much more
I've become much more convinced about it.
And so I'm going to just mention it.
And I think the it would
yeah,
I think it's a kind of challenge to the
FIP community maybe.
And I kind of thought, yeah,
I think they are kind of aware of this
now or so.
The thing is that there is no example
for which all of the fip
blanket conditions
the for the four conditions I mentioned
have been proven to hold.
So we don't know any one equation
that appears
all of these conditions
are actually I forgot the statistic
maybe should be
but yeah
there's no loss of any equation
with the steady state that
okay so
so what this means is
we don't even know if there's any system
that the FIP ID method applies
or that this statement that
in very short
that the FIP blanket implies
an agent,
that this is
like we don't know that there's a system
for which this is true.
So this also means we cannot we can never
check like there's no system
we could look at and check if
there is actually something to invasion
inference and in what way is doing it
and that it's actively this version.
So this is kind of
it's it's not yeah.
I mean, like it would be kind of cool to
like say in some way this is the whole
Marco of bank story or yeah, the whole
is like FIP agent ID
story might not might be vacuous.
Like this is what this says.
And I think it's kind of a
serious point and it should be
addressed, I think.
Okay, so maybe some notes on this.
So there's this primordial soup example
in the origin of API and it's used,
I mean the life as we know it
and it's also used in the monographs,
but there's no proof that this thing has
a steady state or that this steady state
or based MVC
type time synchronous.
Michael Microphone
and also of course, there's no proof
that it has a sigma since
because in life as we know,
it wasn't even any sigma function.
Also this the
like you could say
maybe the constructed FIP agents
are systems that
obey all these conditions but and
I mean maybe they are even some of that,
but this connection is never made
explicitly.
It's always just there's
this claim that they are based on this,
on these first principles
of this, all of this, but
it's never shown, for example,
that the agent environment
combination,
which forms this Markov process,
that it has a steady state distribution.
And it's actually very unlikely
that in all of them
it has a steady state distribution.
And actually, you can kind of think
I would argue that it's actually not
true.
Definitely not for all of them.
And also, even if
this agent environment
pair would have a steady state
distribution,
we would still
want to see that it appears to us.
MVC Right.
And also that it's kind of question
So I should mention that this
this is like the second file
that checking that the ABC holds
is an idea.
That's right. And that's anywhere. Well,
and there's some
arguments about it,
but I won't go into it
the so furthermore
it is never checked like
we never look at the sigma function
which appears to play a significant role,
but we never look at the sigma function
in these constructed
FP agents.
What's what is kind of what I'm
pretty sure that it says it's
satisfied in a reasonable way
is the vector field condition.
Okay Yeah.
And maybe this
I don't know why I say this here, but
yeah.
Like, okay, so you could you could
so you could maybe so since we had Felix
or we used to on one
because this is to show various
things about
the free energy
and we, we know that it
satisfies
quite a few of it
satisfies, three of these assumptions.
So since first effect of your condition,
we can make it so that it satisfies
the NBC and the solid either condition,
but there is no such system like a
so basically I'm like
if you want to, there's no such system
that has the signal function.
So if you wanted to search
for an on central back process
that base,
that is basically an existence proof.
Then I can tell you it's impossible.
So this proof is kind of unpublished, but
and it's mostly due to Felix, but
you know, maybe, maybe I'm going to,
maybe you're going to put it on archive
at some point.
It's really not.
Okay. So that's this point.
Now I want to make another point
that is not in our paper
and then we're going to slowly
get to the end
because the last point isn't
substantial.
Okay. So
yeah, what I want to say
is that there are agents
in the literature
for which the
the system that they are contained in.
So if we form the environment,
if we look at the environment,
at the agent combination
as a markov process,
what I talked about in the very beginning
then and, and the
the agent is this FP agent
then for some of them it's
straightforward to show
that they that this combination, this
this resulting Markov process
does not have a steady state.
And the first thing to note
is that if you have some kind of some
monotonously increasing counter,
it can never
if your state contains
a more monotonously increasing
counter, it means you can never return
to the previous state.
And this means
you cannot have a state state
because the states are not recurrent.
And that means there's no steady state.
So as I mentioned before,
the internal state,
the entire age and state of FP
agents, hyper parameters
and updated
using Bayesian inference
variation of Bayesian inference,
but that also
includes exact patient inference.
And so
these hyper parameters of expectation
inference, they accumulate evidence,
which means they count
occurrences of events
and they only count up
and they count every and for every event
they count something.
So they are contested always.
They are monotonously increasing.
And for example
in the sophisticated inference paper
is if you look at equation 4.5,
there is one
there's an explicit equation
for the updating
of one of the parameters which counts
the occurrences of transitions
from, expected environment, space
to observations,
and no such counter
can be obtained within
any Markov chain that has a steady state.
So this means that this agent,
this particular agent
in the sophisticated inference paper,
is not within
such a system that has a steady state.
So it's not within
the system that
as subsystem
it cannot exist
within a subsystem database.
The conditions of the
the identification.
Okay.
So this
so the be aware that this statement also
published
that I kind of want to
put this out there
because it would be boring
if I just talked about it's already
published. And
so, I mean,
there's
some constant advice of what I think. But
if you want to look at this
at a very simple example of this,
I published a paper last year on this.
And so I'm pretty sure I mean this
it seems pretty straightforward.
This argument.
And then one I think that so
in this paper sophisticated inference
also there is some
argument about steady state
in the appendix A to
but that steady state just kind of
just it ignores in terms of the
it only looks at the other variables.
So I think
and I think that's actually necessary.
I think there's just no steady state
if you're increasing
the intensity of the edge.
So maybe if you have this stent
Yeah, the consequences of this are that
FP agents
are not identified by the FP agent ID
methods
and T and this also means
that the FP agents cannot be modified
by this
FP agent ID or or by first principles
because they think they violate
these first principles.
In this case
at least this.
Okay, I think that was
at this point, the last point is kind of
being a bit nit picky,
but I think it's also kind of important
for some people, and that is that this
identification
method is changing in the literature.
And you shouldn't think, for example,
that the original F as we know
it, a paper
comes from tense, a method
that's very similar to the nuance.
I mean, the is constructions of the most
like the internal and external state.
They don't appear there's
no sigma function.
But in the later
versions of these things,
these constructions play a central role.
So these two, they are two
different methods and
okay and
and they are one of these things
we did in our papers, we showed that
this original method in life
as we know it is kind of form.
But well,
well, where did I go?
This is and so
okay, don't worry.
We're not going to look at all
these slides.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
So we we've kind of looked at this
and we think it's wrong,
at least the way it stated.
LDA okay, so,
so be aware that if you look at this
method, I thought maybe,
maybe just ignore the life as we know it.
Paper. Let's think of what I want to say.
And also like
you can't tell from the literature that
this method is very different.
I mean, it's of they never say why
they changed it and kind of
still are mentioned
as the basis of these things.
So be aware, it's kind of
maybe it's a waste of time
reading this thing.
Okay, that's it.
In summary,
what I said is that we can separate the
literature into agent ID,
FP, Agent ID and FP Agent Construction,
and that the FBI agent identification
method requires
significantly more assumptions than just
whatever the mark of length
it was in the beginning
that this
agent identification method,
this is an example
that would prove that that such systems
actually exist, such systems
with agents, that systems
with such agents actually exist.
And it requires a steady
state
that at least some of the FBI agents
definitely don't satisfy.
The method has changed from its original,
but also not.
It could still be correct.
I don't know.
Like maybe there are enough assumptions
you can make
and maybe that also systems that
contain situations,
it could all still work out.
But I haven't made it
through all of these derivations.
So there may also be
I guess there may be even more
some that's okay
at the last point
that FP agent construction
the FBI agent is probably unaffected
by any of these problems of the FP agent
ID that
all the good stuff if you want
okay and it can be okay.
And this method can be probably
independently motivated
by some other arguments
that are first principles, if you like.
Okay, that's it.
I think a lot of people are looking to me
about this stuff.
Yeah, and that's it.
Thank you very much for your attention.
If you made it all the way,
especially if you made it all the.
Thank you, Martin.
Maybe you can share and I'll just ask
a few of the questions from the chat.
In closing.
Okay.
Well, it's it's it's
the last day, I'm sure.
Is it the same as.
Maybe
go back to the GC and just on share.
Sheets.
Yeah. Cool.
That's great. Great.
Nice. Cool.
Okay, perfect. So great.
Thanks again.
That was really awesome and I hope people
paid attention.
So the first question is from Peter.
And Peter asked The distinction
between agent
identification
and agent construction is very nice.
If I wanted to use that distinction
in my own work, should I cite your paper
or is this distinction made elsewhere to.
I'm wondering if I
if I mentioned this anywhere.
I don't know. Actually, I don't know.
I mean, like it's in some way
it's just yeah, it's kind of like a
yeah, it's kind of like an observation
that makes most sense.
And it's been yeah, I don't know. No.
I think if I, if I think of something,
maybe, I don't know what can I see.
I on Twitter, I mean maybe I've got
it posted on Twitter.
Follow me on Twitter.
Sounds cool. But yeah, I'm not sure.
And I think it's kind of an obvious thing
I'm not the only one who has
I'm definitely not the only one who has
observed this.
I yeah, probably there's somebody
in the literature that did it in 1950.
But yeah,
I think I'm not going to be mad at you
if you don't say it is.
Thanks for the response.
Another question from Peter
is how much should
the agent's ID and agent construction
depend on each other?
In other words,
how big is the problem if they don't?
And how important is it
that it comes from first principles?
I was going to say
the first sentence saying.
How much should the agent's ID
and agent construction
depend on each other?
Okay, so are those like
two separate lines or one integrated
whole?
Yeah, good question. I mean,
I guess, I mean, in
I guess ideally there would be
some kind of relation, but
on the other hand, so
we want to construct agents like so.
So in my opinion, the bacteria agents.
But when we do agent construction,
we don't really care.
We don't have to
follow the principle of bacteria
necessarily if we don't like either.
We have I mean, we might be
we might have to because that's just
how physics work
or due to the constraints of physics.
But if we don't have to,
then nothing should stop us
just constructing any kind of thing that
we want. I mean, like
like if we
yeah.
So I guess they are not
necessarily dependent.
I mean
at least they can again see the so
on the other hand, I guess it would be
it would also be nice
if you have some kind of.
Yeah.
If you still have some agent ID method
which comprises all possible agents,
like all agents that you construct
should be
examples of your like should be
detectable identifiable by your agent.
Identify.
Okay, now I'm
going to take back what I said before.
They should be nuanced
and I hope.
I hope this helped a little bit.
Yep. And, and I'll just give why I think.
There's probably more to say,
but I can't at the moment.
I can really think of its. Yeah.
So here's one
final question and is a question I had,
but I'll use the phrasing of Peter here.
And so this will be our closing question
and hopefully the beginning of something
new in the beginning of moving forward.
Peter wrote,
I suppose the mathematics in free energy
principle and, active inference
could be taken as a work in progress.
Are there suggestions
for how to solve or work with the issues
that you're raising?
Just any thoughts on this could be nice.
So where do we go as learners and doers
and practitioners and communicators
in active inference? So,
so yeah, like I said,
I mean, on the one hand you can
if you if you construct agents,
you can just ignore
all of the stuff
I said because in my opinion
you're not relying on this
agent ID method anyway.
So, so there's no problem like of course
you could maybe wonder what this
base optimal
that is sometimes mentioned
in the literature of the FP
what this really means
and where it comes from. Like
I think that's I find it,
I always think it's a little bit vague
what it really means.
And it's actually such a trivial question
what based off
thoughts on what optimize.
But yeah, mostly you can ignore
this.
FP And ID, but if you are interested
in the FP ID
then yeah, I mean, this
I guess the the thing is
look at either,
I mean, try to understand
where it's actually going.
I mean like I still haven't
really understood these little parts
of the, the monograph
where
everything is supposed to come together
because I always get stuck
before in some equations
that I don't understand.
And then I think they're wrong,
but I'm not sure they're wrong yet.
It's I would have mentioned that,
but there's some
way I don't and I suspect they're wrong.
But yeah I'm still not sure. And
but yeah, I guess that's the like
I don't really see like
if you want to save something of this
method, then look at this.
But another another.
So is maybe to think about or
think about this for yourself.
Think about what it
what are the conditions
you think under which something is doing.
Bayesian inference or something like this
and ignore all the math
by the end
that's already in the literature
and then try like once you've figured it
for yourself, maybe try to
come back to the literature
and compare it or something.
Because I sometimes think
people will like too much
on what this what the literature says.
And I'm not really sure that actually
what's in the literature
is like it doesn't strike me
as a very straightforward argument
and I like straightforward arguments.
I think straightforward
arguments are usually better.
I think maybe there isn't
a straightforward argument,
but I kind of think I always think
there's a straightforward argument.
That's just my opinion. You know so.
Well.
It's a nice point that the literature
is a scaffold for our own
thinking in development.
The literature is not a road
that's been with gold,
and it's just perfect in the past.
It's actually always a work in progress
and always a scaffold.
So thanks so much for sharing
this really work.
Progress.
Not that it isn't with landmarks
that you've published, but
it is a work in progress
in the bigger sense.
So also, thanks for staying up late
to bring us this information
and we hope that in future livestreams
we can unpack this
more and hear updates as you continue
to progress on this line of research.
Okay.
Thank you very much for having me.
Thank you, Martin.
Peace!
Bye.